I sort of see our company as the modern
versions of Apple Computer or Dell
computer where the platform where
they're innovating and experimenting on
is no longer computer parts but the
human body in a world where you have
perfect access to information via the
Internet
and computing power becomes more and
more ubiquitous than the human brain is
a machine is going to become more and
more valuable there in the
differentiator for a lot of people is
going to be how high of a level they can
perform at in 2014 Geoffrey Wu and
Michael Brandt founded the startup nutri
box that sells so-called nootropics
pills designed to enhance memory
cognition and mental stamina while all
their ingredients are fda-approved the
pills are formulated using a combination
of peer-reviewed studies and what nutri
box calls rose science so a nutri box
we've actually created products for
these particular sort of aspect of the
day rise is meant to be taken every day
because it affects compound over time so
one of the ingredients at rise for
instance is the co bubble airy and
that's been shown when you take it
eventually it increases baseline
[Music]
you also want product on Sprint which is
more of an acute pick-me-up
think of it as a replacement for your
espresso aircon that sprint rise and yon
known as a sleep aid helps you go to bed
at night and have a great night of sleep
and be rejuvenated in the morning nutri
box is targeting upwardly mobile
professionals who want an edge but
aren't interested in prescription drugs
like adderall the cofounders have raised
more than two point five million in
funding there's a question about whether
there's a sense of soft coercion around
nootropics like it that if the three
people sitting next to you at work are
doing it are you also then pressured to
do it and to an extent the answer is yes
everyone at nutri box takes the
nootropics they make daily and it's just
one part of their plan to become more
perfect humans through something called
bio hacking the idea of bio hacking is
that you look at your human body like a
system so the same way that you can look
at a computer you have a desired output
or you have a desired input and you
basically start modulating those things
so you want better cognitive output
there's maybe something you can do to
cause that to happen
so we've wholly dive into the world of
bio hacking that's constantly using our
nootropics and constantly testing new
formulations for digital base
intermittent fasting is another part of
nutri boxes suggested biohacking routine
all eight of the company's employees
fast for 36 or 60 hours each week and we
do this as a way to one increase the
growth of neurons and to boost level of
agility factors you know so basically
extending our potential lifespan
on Tuesdays when we're fasting one of
the highlights of the day is always
doing a fast and work out something
that's not super intensive on the body
your body actually when you're fasting
gets this almost a cheetah's this light
this heightened sense of physicality
like a warrior or something where you're
you're hungry and you want to go do
something
[Music]
the day after their fasting workout
nutri boxes co-founders host a communal
breakfast at a friend's restaurant we
have a breakfast you know as you know
2025 people show up every Wednesday
morning of 8 a.m. where people are
constantly trading tips about
intermittent fasting and other
biohacking regimens and tools they use
it's good
good to eat after 36 hours nutri box is
now completing a study that compares
this products print to pure caffeine
it's also developing an app for
wearables that lets users measure the
effects of nootropics on their bodies
there's still a lot of work to be done
no one knows whether these products
actually work and the results seem to
differ from person to person
according to woo the stakes are high in
a way it's almost like our main humanity
against AI and robots from taking
everything over
[Music]